in his easter sunday address pope
francis has urged world leaders to hear
the calls for peace in what he described
as an easter of war
the pontiff told the tens of thousands
of people gathered at saint peter's
square that the world needed love and
reconciliation
now more than ever and referenced
several conflicts around the world
he described the fighting in ukraine as
quote cruel and senseless
this was the first easter sunday mass
with a crowd in two years due to the
coronavirus pandemic
for more let's bring in dw religious
affairs analyst martin gak martin the
pope's easter address this year comes at
a time of crisis in europe what did he
say about that
well i mean
again has had a very strong diplomatic
arm
that it has exercise in in order to try
to bring peace to different
conflict regions i think it was somewhat
unexpected that the pope would be
talking or the vatican would be
concentrating its efforts in europe uh
and most of what we heard is actually a
plea uh for peace and a plea for uh
essentially for
you know unity unity a brotherly
brotherly unity uh across europe uh
particularly in the face of a possible
escalation and this was actually this
loom quite large in the in the speech in
which the pope actually warned of
escalation becoming really a form of
violence that could potentially not be
stopped and could have enormously
devastating effects for humankind he
said
now does the pope's opinion on this war
matter to russia or is he just um
preaching to the choir as you could say
look i mean it's it's extremely
difficult to say how is it that moscow
is receiving what have been increasingly
critical uh you know
essentially messages from from the
vatican the vatican has been quite clear
over the last three weeks although at
the beginning it actually did take
a much slower approach to condemning
moscow precisely because they have a
very strong diplomatic approach to
conflict
and they have a very broad sort of a
very broad muscle or very large
diplomatic muscle but now the vatican
has become much clearer as to the
criticism it's not really clear that you
know the kremlin cares at all what is
that that is said in rome but it is
quite clear that the the the kremlin
understands how brought the base of the
vatican and of the catholic church is
including not only inside the ukraine
inside ukraine but also inside russia
i want to talk about the pope's health
as well because on saturday he attended
the easter vigil mass but he didn't lead
it and some think that's because of leg
pain what what do you know about this
this is mostly speculation but this is
precisely the the rumor that is
circulating that you know he has his uh
knee problem has prevented him from
leading uh saturday evening where he had
to be mostly standing for about three
hours uh today he started actually
though he said darwis which he did lead
the mass this morning uh he started
standing the the the speech the luisa
darvis but actually halfway through he
sat down uh so you know i mean this does
not seem to be a major health concern uh
but it does seem to be impeding
his movement and some of his offices
dw religious affairs analyst martin gak
thank you
you're welcome
you